[Music]  the Duggar family is making headlines  again this time counting on star derick  dillard who was married to Jill Duggar  appears to be at the center of the drama  usually work as a great team on  Wednesday an unverified Twitter account  under his name tweeted a disapproving  message aimed at fellow TLC reality star  jazz Jennings I am a teenage girl I'm  also a soccer player I'm also  transgender and I'm proud of that the  tweet read what an oxymoron a reality  show which follows a non reality  transgender is a myth gender is not  fluid it's ordained by God that ignited  a Twitter firestorm Dillard's alleged  account later replied to one user  tweeting I want to be clear I have  nothing against him I only have issue  with the words and definitions being  propagated here et is reached out to  Dillard and the Duggars as well as  Jennings and TLC for comments  [Music]